je vous livre est un calcul d'ordre de
grandeur qui va peut-être vous
intéressez vous avez problème entendu
parler du grand paris le coût
d'investissement des infrastructures du
grand paris avant le fameux facteur pis
vous savez entre le budget et le coût
réel une fois que le truc est terminée
rigole parce que l'autre jour j'ai
entendu duflot à la radio dire est ce
que vous connaissez un autre truc que le
p r pour lequel le coup double en cours
de route et c'est dommage que j'ai pas
été à côté d'elle parce que j'ai eu
envie de lui dire tout prototype
industriel
le facteur pis il est valable absolument
partout et c'est vrai aussi dans les
développements de logiciels fameux
facteur pis vous avez entre le truc qui
fait papa maman qu'on vous vend pour
cent qui finira par coûter 300 à
l'arrivée au bourget valent absolument
partout donc pour revenir à la question
posée dans le domaine des transports
donc le grand paris à peu près 60
milliards d'euros
nos calculs c'est que ça va déplacer de
l'ordre de 2 à 3 % de la mobilité
motorisée des franciliens explications
explications ou bien vous mettez les
lignes de transports en commun dans des
zones denses où déjà très peu de gens
utilisent en voiture jean march
utilisent le bus utilisent le métro etc
donc vous allez avoir essentiellement du
report modal en provenance de gens qui
ne se déplace pas en voiture plus de
l'induction trafic l'induction de trafic
c'est moins chez moi j'avais l'intention
de rester chez moi puisque métro passant
présent en bas de chez moi je le prends
et je me baladais ailleurs et bien le
vrai report modal en provenance de la
voiture il est marginal dans cette
histoire ou bien vous mettez en zones
peu denses
vous faites une station de métro mieux
de la pampa c'est-à-dire au plateau de
saclay et à ce moment comme la zone
d'attraction de la gare est de 1 à 2
kilomètres si vous êtes en zones peu
denses vous attirez personnes et donc
personne avec une voiture enfin les gens
ont tous une voiture mais il en a tiré
pas beaucoup ils vont directement lieu
voilà et soit dit en passant la
construction des stations de métro dans
la pampa c'est-à-dire à saclay va
commencer par produire un premier effet
qui est que dès qu'on saura que la
station de métro va se construire ont
construit à côté pour héberger des gens
qui habiteront à perpète parce qu'à ce
moment là il y aura pas le métro et
viendront en voiture
et le jour où il y aura le métro ils
déménageront pas de père pète de la wii
sont pour aller se mettre ailleurs donc
vous aurez mis les gens dans un squeeze
dans un corner dont ils ne sortiront pas
parce que le métro arrive ce truc là et
tu es tf1 je dirais tu es une très bonne
idée en 1940 probablement au fonds en
aujourd'hui c'est totalement
anachronique vous parler d'eux
nagement du grand paris les trucs en
petite couronne sont intelligents les
trucs en grande couronne c'est du délire
complet vous pardonnez moi d'utiliser
cette expression n'est certes pas du
tout en phase avec les enjeux auxquels
on va devoir faire face
pas du tout donc pour en revenir à ce
que c'est du gaspillage d'argent public
total pour en revenir à ce que je disais
sur les transports dont 60 milliards
le grand paris 2 à 3% de la mobilité
motorisée je reprends l'exemple de mes
voitures qui consomment pas beaucoup
donc je commence par planter des
banderilles dans le dos de renault et de
peugeot ils me sortent mes deux chevaux
et là je vais une prime à la casse sur
la totalité du prix d'achat de la
voiture pour tous les ménages
franciliens qui mettent à la casse leur
voiture à 6 litres aux cent pour
m'acheter ma voiture un litre et demi il
ya 6 millions de voitures en ile de
france six millions fois 10060 milliard
dans le premier cas de figure
j'ai changé la vie de trois pour cent
des gens qui consomment qui utilise une
voiture dans le deuxième cas de figure
j'ai changé la vie de tous les gens qui
utilisent une voiture pour la même somme
d'argent public la même et si vous
voulez pas dans le même temps que la tei
pp se casse la figure parce que vous
allez consommer quatre fois moins de
carburant vous multipliez le prix de
l'essence par trois cqfd c'est
exactement ce que je vous dit leur donc
c'est ça donc voilà un exemple de mesure
dans laquelle vous avez résolu le
problème à urbanisme constant parce que
c'est pas en disant que vous allez faire
déménager de banlieue lointaine tous les
gens qui n'auront plus rien à y faire
dans 50 pour ça il vous faut 50 à son
temps en version sympathique sinon vous
des portes et tout le monde sait pas
sympathique donc en version sympathique
pour modifier la forme des villes faut
50 à 100 ans
et pour répondre à la contrainte
pétrolières qui commence à s'exercer
aujourd'hui et qui va devenir
particulièrement mordante dans les 10 à
20 à 15 ans qui viennent
vous n'avez pas d'autre choix que de
baisser très très vite à technologie
constante parce que le seul truc qu'on
sait faire facilement aujourd'hui c'est
des voitures à pétrole
la consommation unitaire des véhicules
et à ce compte là vous sauver vous
sauvez la stabilité dans une bonne
partie de la couronne francilienne